look what's going on in Argentina right
now this is absolutely spectacular this
is from the N wokeness Twitter account
18 days ago president Javier Malay was
inaugurated in Argentina since then
eliminated 12 out of 21 cabinet posts
firing 5,000 government employees ending
380,000 government regulations banned
woke language in the military ill to
affirm the right to self-defense Bill to
legalize homeschooling of kids proposal
to punish out to punish all Riot
organizers future welfare cuts for Road
blocking legalized paying contracts in
Bitcoin privatization of state-run
companies opened up the Argentina oil
industry doesn't that all sound freaking
amazing and it's because the people of
Argentina had gotten so close to the
precipice of true communism and
socialism every single bullet point that
I just put up there are the things that
we should be doing here in the United
States